you know it's weird because everybody  who is saying that this was a  mathematical impossibility so i'm  hearing you say it i don't know if  you're familiar who mike lindell is he  sells pillows on television i don't know  if you've heard of him i've heard of him  yes yeah he says it's a mathematical  impossibility  sometimes lawyers who have no training  in mathematics say it's a mathematical  impossibility but then you go to actual  statisticians and they say there's  nothing here that raises any red flags  whatsoever do you think there's some  reason why it's non-mathematicians that  are convinced about the mathematical  impossibility i'm trying to figure that  out  um i ought to bet that if you ask  mathematicians um you will find that  they will say these are highly irregular  numbers especially the two cases i cited  you so  i believe that there are many who would  admit that these numbers are impossible  okay